each leader had their own image from the
virtual g7 meeting and together the idea
was a show of strength and unity there
has after all been little of either this
past week
led by boris johnson the consensus was
to persuade president biden that more
time was needed to complete the
withdrawal they wanted an extension to
the august 31st deadline the american
president disagreed
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
of course invidious as it may be
delaying the u.s departure wasn't a
decision president biden could make
without a guarantee from the taliban
that it would continue to cooperate with
america the president is being advised
from the ground that an attack against
coalition forces is a growing danger and
from the taliban spokesman the message
couldn't have been clearer
it's something that's been against the
agreement
all people should be removed prior to
that date and that is why dialogue
between america their intermediaries and
the taliban is absolutely key it's
striking that it was the cia director
who met the leader of the taliban this
week in kabul that shows just how high
level these talks are the qataris will
also play a key role in the days ahead
my understanding is that they are doing
all they can if not to extend that
deadline then at least to allow safe
passage of people to continue after the
americans have left
[Music]
in the absence of any progress there the
british prime minister is looking longer
term we've got together the the leading
western powers and agreed uh not just a
uh
joint approach to dealing with the the
evacuation but also a road map for the
way in which we're going to engage uh
with
the taliban yet from the un's human
rights chief a grim assessment of the
reality summary executions of civilians
and all the combat members of the afghan
national security forces
restrictions on the right of women
including the right to move around
freely and girl's right to attend school
recruitment of child soldiers and
repression of peaceful protests and
expression of descent
the u.s president has been consistent
throughout this process holding his
position through such chaos
now it is the taliban apparently calling
the shots over the coalition withdrawal
mark stone sky news at the white house